if you do these five things you will win
with money one hundred percent of the
time number one you need to have a
written plan a budget no one
accidentally wins second thing is you
got to get out of debt your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income and when you spend your whole
freaking life giving your money to Banks
who fill up the skyline and have
furniture nicer than yours that makes
you stupid number three live on less
than you make you need to decide that my
life is not good enough the way it is
and so I am going to control the
controllables I am going to change some
things and then you're going to save
some money you know how rich people get
rich they save money and if you'll get
out of debt you'll invest and you live
on less than you make and you have a
plan then you can do the last one it's
the most fun you'll ever have with money
you can be outrageously generous